autodefensa o una puerta abierta a la
tragedia desde estos dos puntos de vista
se abordó el tema del acceso a las armas
durante una audiencia en la comisión de
supervisión de la cámara de
representantes en la que también se
escucharon las voces de sobrevivientes y
familiares de los fallecidos en la
reciente masacre de oval de donde un
tirador de 18 años acabó con la vida de
19 niños y dos maestras
pero lo que sí encontré fue algo que
ninguna oración aliviará jamás dos niños
cuyos cuerpos habían sido pulverizados
por las balas que le dispararon
decapitados cuyas carnes habían sido
desgarradas
cuando fui hacia los bolsos él le
disparó a mi amigo que estaba cerca de
mí y pensé que él iba a regresar al
cuarto así que agarré la sangre y la
puse toda sobre mí
y qué hiciste cuando te pusiste toda la
sangre encima
me quedé quieta y toma el teléfono de mi
maestra y llamé al 911
aún con la contundencia de los
testimonios el debate continuó abierto
entre quienes apoyan y quienes siguen
rechazando el control de armas por clive
existe un lugar importante para que los
propietarios de armas respetuosos de la
ley sirvan para protegerse a sí mismos a
sus familias ya sus comunidades de la
violencia las reacciones instintivas
para imponer políticas de control de
armas no son las respuestas figuras como
el actor matthew mcconaughey y nativo de
hualde y el alcalde de nueva york eric
adams quien abogó por una solución a la
violencia armada se hicieron presentes
en la audiencia es hora de decidir si es
más importante proteger las ganancias de
los fabricantes de armas o la vida de
nuestros niños ruth el panel del
congreso se reunió mientras un grupo
bipartidista de senadores negocia para
ver si hay forma de alcanzar algún
compromiso sobre la seguridad de las
armas que demócratas y republicanos
puedan aceptar